estas son algunas hectáreas del terreno
que el pueblo que quiere recuperar una
tierra fértil arrebatada la protección
indígena entre esas personas es muy
triste la sociedad brasileña necesita
entender que no queremos nada que
pertenezca a otra persona sólo queremos
lo que está documentado esas son las
tierras tradicionales de los pueblos
choclán trans soldado o pobre
como los del pueblo chaplin los reclamos
de miles de indígenas están en riesgo
por el denominado marco temporal la
iniciativa establece que los pueblos
indígenas sólo pueden reclamar las
tierras en las que se encontraban desde
1988 cuando se estableció la última
constitución de brasil esto dejaría por
fuera todos los territorios desde los
cuales los pueblos ancestrales fueron
desplazados sistemáticamente y
significaría un serio revés para la
demarcación de tierras de los pueblos
originarios
ante la expectativa del fallo del
supremo unos cinco mil indígenas se
movilizaron a brasilia la capital
queremos cuidar nuestros territorios a
nuestros mayores y nuestros niños por
eso estamos en brasilia para obtener
algún reconocimiento porque la gente no
nos reconoce como verdaderos brasileños
más allá de la batalla legal detrás hay
intereses económicos las tierras que ya
no pertenecen a los indígenas podrían
ser pedidas para hacer redes viales y
para la explotación de recursos además
de ser apetecidas por la industria
cárnica respaldada por el presidente ya
ir personaron
sonar en el contexto del actual gobierno
de bolsonaro un gobierno que la gente
considera anti indígena y que quiere a
todo costo exterminar a los pueblos
indígenas es todavía más importante que
unamos fuerzas para que el marco
temporal sea derrotado para que
para ustedes está derrotada
de aprobarse la ley los grandes
perdedores serían los pueblos
ancestrales pero también el medio
ambiente